what's up guys I'm zakari and I'm here
with
BuzzFeed I like to blend a lot of folk
guar bring in real instruments my mom
was a musician so so many artists I'm
inspired by this next project is going
to be titled Bliss it's really just a
collection of experiences over the last
few years went to Alaska to go work as a
dishwasher so it was just me and my
guitar really it was interesting
experience coming from a city and then
going into the Wilderness I had the
realization that if you're going to be
alone and you're going to have to live
that way that you need do it that way
there's a lot of growth and questioning
things and just chasing answers in this
[Music]
project